more on this right now let's bring in
martian his former white house
speechwriter washington post columnist
fox news contributor the co-host of the
podcast
what the hell is going on and he's on
your tv set right now you wrote an
op-ed about this in which you said quote
you've heard the expression that the
cover-up is worse than the crime
well in the case of new york governor
andrew cuomo the opposite might be
true you've been listening to this along
with us mark your thoughts
yeah well first i wish i could give
genestein a hug right now because i
can't imagine how she's feeling watching
uh andrew cuomo say the things that he
said
uh there are so many lies to unpack in
what he just said but
let's start just with what you were
talking about the fact is that it's not
republicans who are accusing him of
under counting
the debts it's the new york's democratic
attorney general the state of new york
who said that he did not report as uh
the data
on people who who were nursing home
residents who later were taken to
hospitals and died there
counting them as as nursing home debts
and that undercounted the number of
nursing home debts
by a significant margin he said that
they cooperated with the justice
department immediately
that's not true there were two requests
from the justice department the first
one came from the civil rights division
i interviewed people from the justice
department who explained this to me
the first one came from the civil rights
division which has jurisdiction over
just
government nursing homes which is only a
couple dozen in the state of new york
and they requested the data
on whether or not they they were what
the reporting on nursing home deaths
they responded to that the cuomo
administration and the data was so
skewed that the civil civil rights
division folks went to the civil
division which is the one that has
jurisdiction over
private nursing homes in new york uh
which is the vast majority of nursing
homes and asked them to make the same
request
they did cuomo stonewalled that request
they didn't provide the data until the
last days of the trump administration
because they were trying to wait out the
trump administration thinking they'd get
better treatment
from the biden administration yeah and
so let's do this once this point
john sure go ahead yeah go ahead no no
go ahead
finish your point no and then then the
the real the real
tragedy of what he did is in addition to
the causing additional nursing home
deaths by putting sick people in the
nursing homes
is not that he lied to the justice
department he lied
starting in may to public health
officials who were desperately trying to
understand how this new
virus had reached us who was vulnerable
who was dying where they were dying
because they were trying to combat this
it's that's like providing false
intelligence to battlefield
commanders in the middle of a battle in
a time of war they were trying to indeed
and this
what's important is the new york variant
of the virus is the one that spread
across the united states it wasn't the
west coast variant that came straight
from china it was the
east coast variant that arrived in new
york and new york ceded the pandemic
across the entire country
so if you provide false data about who's
dying in new york
you're undermining the national effort
to fight this this virus and that's what
andrew cuomo did
you know that was a point that i was
just about to bring up with you i wanted
to
put a little bit more of your op-ed up
there but we don't need to now since you
have articulated it
but compare and contrast what you just
said
with what cuomo said where he said his
big mistake
was that we didn't fight back
aggressively enough in this
void i was not aggressive enough in
knocking down the falsities
i mean there's a there's a lot of
daylight between what you say he did
and what he says his mistake was
well i mean again he's not fighting with
me he's not fighting with republicans
he's not fighting with the trump
administration the people who are
calling him out
is the democratic attorney general the
state of new york democratic state
legislatures including
uh some who lost loved ones in in in
these nursing homes and want to know the
truth
he's he's in a fight with his own side
so you know to try and make this out
like some
conservatives are trying to call him out
and this false you know crocodile tears
about the poor people who uh
who lost people in in nursing homes when
we now know
that more people died in nursing homes
because of his policies and then he'd
lied to cover it up
undermined the public health uh response
across the united states the i mean just
just some data seventy percent of the
coveted cases in texas came from new
york 78
from wisconsin 80 from alaska 80 in
arizona 100
louisiana came from the new york variant
so it was vital
in our public health response to
understand who was dying where they were
dying
who was vulnerable how people were dying
because that was feeding our response
across the country
and cuomo provided our public health
experts in washington at the cdc at the
department of health
with false data false intelligence that
made that
help impeded their ability to understand
how this pandemic was spreading so he
didn't just hurt new yorkers
he heard kovitz covet victims across the
united states
that is a that is impeachable offense i
think it's a uh a safe assumption to say
that uh his news conference this
afternoon does not put this to rest by
any stretch of the imagination
marxist good to talk to you thanks so
much and and sandra
again we have a case here of the
governor of new york not saying
okay we we made a mistake by putting
these uh
folks back in nursing homes where it
spread like wildfire we accept
responsibility for that
he is again saying not my fault check
with your republican friends they're the
ones who are at the root of this but
again as mark thiessen points out
he's getting it as much from democrats
as he is from republicans on this issue
absolutely and he continues to point to
what he calls a
void in information that led to rumors
and misinformation about this story
he also talked about the 24-hour news
stations
there's information that does not get
corrected it gets repeated
and then people think it's true so he is
still playing the blame game
and again we'll have those two brothers
coming up who were directly affected by
this
looking forward to that and again one of
the critical points of what he just said
right now is he insisted that the
numbers were fully reported that all of
the deaths were counted
but they weren't counted according to
the attorney general of new york the way
that they should have right
that the deaths in nursing homes were
under-reported so maybe they had an
aggregate figure
but they didn't break it down in such a
way that epidemiologists and medical
experts could say
we got a serious problem here so he has
not started taking questions
at that news conference yet but john
we're going to be monitoring that for
when he does
and talks about this we will get back to